créer des ouvrages paysager qui
s'intègre au site et permettre
valorisation des ressources et réduction
de la consommation d'eau tel était
l'objectif du chantier des jardins
clairière de guyancourt
l'un des 24 aménagements d'île de france
sélectionnés pour la deuxième phase du
concours des victoires du paysage
derrière moi donc il ya les jardins
filtrants en fait qui permettent donc de
traiter des eaux polluées avec
l'utilisation de végétaux ça a permis de
réduire de 60% du coup la consommation
d'eau potable du site donc que ça
équivaut quand même à peu près à 12
piscines olympiques autres sites
sélectionnés à magny les hameaux les
berges nord du bassin du buisson on
était totalement réaménagé platelage
100% chaîne de normandie ont remplacé
les talus et sentiers boueux
le but de l'opération était de rendre
totalement accessible de les pontons et
les berges du bassin des buissons qui
était dans un piteux état
quand on est arrivé et donc on a rendu
accessible peu près 130 mètres linéaires
de de platelage y compris un ponton
spécifique pour les pmr dans les
personnes à mobilité réduite
pour cette deuxième étape du concours
les membres du jury ont effectué des
visites techniques des différents
aménagements afin d'examiner qualité et
originalité des projets au delà de
l'accessibilité au delà de
des matériaux locaux des plantes
indigènes
l'aspect esthétique avec ses terrasses
en bois avec ses platelage ces petits
pour ton et c est très intéressant dans
ce cadre naturel la soirée de remise des
prix aura lieu le 8 décembre le public
peut également voter dès maintenant sur
le site internet pour soutenir son
projet préféré depuis 2014 le nombre de
candidatures a augmenté de près de 30%